it's the largest forgiveness for
individual student debt ever but there
is still a lot of uncertainty about
what's next mary jane bellies are
joining us now in studio with what
borrowers should expect mary jane well
many student loan borrower sites have
crashed in the last 24 hours since
president biden's announcement leaving
many to ask do i qualify and how much of
my student debt is covered
the announcement of a student loan
forgiveness plan is a huge sign of
relief for many people but president
biden's plan has many scrambling for
quick answers how much do i qualify for
that's one big question finance educator
elaine rubin sees from her clients and
how much income is determined during
this time right now the way it's stated
is you earn your earned income during
the pandemic 125 000 for individuals 250
for married couples and heads of
household so we're going to have to see
how they really are going to be looking
at that the true dates they're measuring
to determine who's qualified biden also
announced a student loan pause extension
payments are expected to resume january
2023
now the best way to determine if you are
a pell grant recipient is to go on
studentaid.com
well president biden has announced that
any student loan forgiveness is not
taxable
income when filing your taxes so if you
have any questions during tax season
it's recommended you contact your tax
preparer